- You're so cool.
- Oh my god, I was just
looking at you backstage,
at your jeans,
you look amazing.
- You're a total rock star.
- Thank you.
- You came out here with,
this is why they call you
the woman who dresses America.
Only the cool ones though.
- Oh.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Thank you.
- Only the cool Americas.
- Welcome to New York,
by the way.
- Thank you, thank you
so much.
- It's exciting.
- I love it,
I love it here-
- Do you?
- Yes.
- Good, okay,
then you'll stay?
- Yeah.
So you're now a fan favorite of the show,
how does that feel?
- I mean, I think I'm a favorite
of some fans-
- No, you're a fan favorite...
- That are like.
- Everyone was
very excited you were coming.
(audience cheering)
There are people on the crew
that were like, "She's coming?"
I was like, "Oh my gosh, yeah."
- I think what's nice about this season
is that everyone has somebody different
to kind of plug into.
- Yeah.
- We're all pretty different,
like, you know?
- Yeah.
- But that's what makes it
(indistinct).
- It's much more diverse.
I think, between age, and ethnicity,
and background, and age,
I'm the old one.
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
Yeah, no one thinks
about that.
Yeah, I was like no one thinks old
when they look at you
they just think, damn,
I'm not that cool.
- Yeah, no,
that's not what they're thinking,
but thanks.
- Yeah, they are
thinking that.
Wait, did Andy Cohen
have to actually convince you to do it?
- I mean, convince is a strong word,
we had to come-to-Jesus,
so we knew each other, prior.
- Yeah.
- And at the very end we
were sort of getting ready
to do the final decision that
he and I spoke on the phone
and he said exactly that he
didn't want to convince me,
he was like, "You have to
make the decision on your own
because it's a really vulnerable situation
and anything that you
don't want people to know
they will know."
These fans are, they're
like forensic scientists
if any of you are out there.
- Yeah.
- I know you,
I know you know everything.
- Yeah.
So do you have like a tagline?
I feel like everybody has a tagline,
and let's talk about that ring later,
(chuckling) okay?
- Okay.
(all laughing)
- Well, I brought more
of them because, okay,
so I have a line of eyelashes,
'cause I don't have any eyelashes myself,
my lashes may be affordable,
but everything else is priceless.
- Oh, I like that.
- I thought that was good.
- I like that, I like that.
- We did,
my shoes are almost as
high as my expectations.
- Oh!
(audience laughing)
Hey, but you know what
though, that's great,
why would you lower your bar?
- Exactly.
- Yeah,
- Yeah.
- Why would I?
- I think if you expect
excellence for yourself
there's no problem in
expecting that from others.
See, I accept average for myself,
so I accept average
for everyone else.
(all laughing)
- I actually prefer average
I'm much more comfortable.
I was so happy when standing
back there I was so nervous
and then I heard you fumble and I'm like,
see she's-
- Oh my gosh,
just stick around.
- Thank you.
- You're gonna feel great about yourself.
(all laughing)
Yeah.
We're not, my goal is to
be live with this show
and my whole team is like,
"Sure," (clapping).
(all laughing)
It'd be a very different show
if you like to tune into a train wreck.
But yeah, I'm just so ADHD-
- Well, I'm on a show
that's a train wreck, you can-
- I know.
- And people like that.
- And hey, and it's popular
so there we go.
- Yeah.
- So you have
a 17 year old son-
- I do.
- But you're so cool.
So I picture your son being like,
"Mom, is this cool what I'm wearing?"
Does he ever ask you for advice?
- I mean-
- You seem like the cool mom.
- You can ask him that,
I mean, I am kind of surprised
'cause my son who wants to be an engineer
is like-
- Yeah.
- I actually ask him for advice
'cause he has an eye.
There'll be times when I walk out the door
and I'm telling you sometimes it's like,
it's a hot mess, I don't
know what I'm doing.
I get lost from the closet to the,
from of the door,
I don't know-
- Yeah.
- What happens, and he
stops me and he's like,
"Mom, turn around."
I'm like, "Okay."
- And you put something else on?
This is my son,
and he's seven.
- I listen to him, no, oh.
- My son is seven.
- Oh, you are in trouble.
- I was going out on a girl's night,
I was going out on a girl's night
and he was like,
"Oh, well that's a dress."
- Oh, that's never
a good way to start.
(all laughing)
- That's a dress?
I was like, "Okay, observant."
- I know starting with, oh,
is not good.
- He walked me
back into my closet, seven years old,
and was, "You should wear this one,"
I was like, "Okay,"
I did.
(all laughing)
I changed, he shamed me, I was like,
oh god.
- Did you think
he made the right choice for you?
- He did, you know what we keep thinking
that he might be an engineer,
architect, or something,
how he looks at things are patterns,
he's like a little Harry Styles.
- I think my son is, I mean
he wears my gold lame pants.
I'm like, "Damn."
- Oh, Remi would totally
wear that.
- Yeah, I mean,
I'm into it.
- He's a little rockstar.
- I know my little-
- Yeah.
- My little (indistinct).
- But it's
kind of awesome to see too,
because boys growing up
whenever I was a kid,
they would have gotten
beat up where I'm from,
for wearing anything cool.
- Same, same.
- Really like, so.
- Oh.
- Yeah and it's so,
and I think that's why
my son loves New York too
everybody's their own character here
and everybody fits in,
it's awesome.
- I do think,
I remember when I first,
I moved from California,
so I grew up in L.A.-
- Yeah.
- And I remember when I moved here,
I remember walking down the street
and some girl walked by me with blue hair
and it was just kind of
like, she was carrying
a cup of coffee-
- Yeah, it's like a...
- No one cared.
- David and
(indistinct), yeah.
- And I was like,
this is hot I would say.
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- And it's mad, yeah,
everyone's so different.
- I know.
- I love it.
- And it's...
- I heard this weird thing about you,
it's not weird, but-
- Oh god.
- I just love quirky things about people.
I don't even know how I feel about dill,
but you hate dill.
- Dill should not exist.
- I just love that you're,
so this is me with cilantro.
- No, who invented it?
- No, un-uh, so that's
like a weird thing though
it's not like you, it tastes like soap?
- I just, yeah, cilantro,
when people garnish it it, I'm like,
oh, that's so exciting, scoop.
- No, but yeah.
I have a personal vendetta against dill
and I'm not sure why.
- Yeah,
- I think I was hurt by it
somehow.
- Something happened
in your childhood.
- I was hurt by dill somehow.
(audience laughing)
- We all have trauma.
- Things to talk about in therapy.
- Yeah, who hurt you?
- Or on the show?
- Dill.
- Dill hurt me, offended me.